>> Tucker: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MUCH.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT WE
PROMISE TO MONITOR THE ONGOING
RALLY FOR SOME NEWS AND WE HAVE
SOME.
IF THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSED THE
BRETT KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION
ABOUT 5 MINUTES AGO HE SPOKE
ABOUT CHRISTINE FORD, NBC AND
THE CREEPY LAWYER AT THE CENTERF
ALL OF THIS.
>> President Trump: HOW DID
YOU GET HOME?
I DON'T REMEMBER, WHERE IS THE
PLACE?
I DON'T REMEMBER, HOW MANY YEARS
AGO WAS AT?
I DON'T REMEMBER.
I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT NEIGHBORHOOD WAS IT IN?
UPSTAIRS, DOWNSTAIRS, WHERE WAS
IT?
I HAD ONE BEER, THAT'S THE ONLY
THING I REMEMBER.
A MAN'S LIFE IS IN TATTERS.
A MAN'S LIFE IS SHATTERED.
WE HAVE BEEN ANOTHER WOMAN JUST
REPORT BY A SLEAZEBAG LAWYER
NAMED AVIANTE.
IT TURNED OUT EVEN NBC WHO IS AS
BAD AS THEY GET, EVEN NBC
COULDN'T SHIELD HER WITH THAT
INTERVIEW.